even though they do say that dick were a
lot in this movie which surprised me
they say like four times
yeah i had to i had to stop for a moment
be like dick
is that a splash anyone has ever said
i guess maybe back in the day doesn't
lois lane say a comment to the soldiers
about oh
dick measuring does that make sense yeah
superman movie with the most dick
references
ryan wright and i'm jerry welcome
to reasons to see where we give you
reasons to
see and not to see man of steel
let's soar
reason to see number one fresh take on
superman
i really do love this movie a lot
specifically because this is a super
fresh take on superman i've seen a lot
of superman stuff i've seen like all the
original ones with reeves and then i i
saw a lot even the old school cartoons
i've seen
the superman adventures in the 90s
smallville
superman returns a lot of them i heard
what they were going for for a more
realistic a much more darker tone and
when i heard that i was like how the
[ __ ] would you ever do that with
superman and they totally pulled it off
you know just even from my limited scope
it was still like
this does still feel fresh and it does
still feel new superman seems like a
character nowadays
that at least some people are kind of
tired of or
or isn't that interesting to people just
it seems like they haven't done too many
like
reiterations of superman you know it'd
be like with batman they've changed him
up
so many times throughout the years to
kind of expect superman to be different
is a little bit
challenging in one's own mind you know
and i really like
that they took this sort of you know
where do i find the only person like me
where do i fit in the world sort of lost
wandering and i know it's it partly
borrows from uh a superman story called
the wanderer i think
okay or he is just sort of wandering the
earth trying to figure out who he is
and i thought that that works really
well for for you know a new take on
superman and also they played up
you know the science fiction yeah that
was alien side
that was cool especially in the first 10
minutes yeah they really set you up for
yo this is a science fiction movie yeah
exactly like it's fast-paced at the
beginning of the first 10 minutes but
to see like krypton portrayed so unique
like in a way that we've never seen it
portrayed
on a screen before yeah it's fascinating
it almost reminds me just just
in in response as uh like asgard did
in uh thor's like people were like how
are they gonna do that and then it's
really realized and then krypton in this
movie feels very realized and it feels
you know it doesn't feel like you know
silly alien planet
yeah you know especially in the
flashback sequences they have this very
sort of rich
americana kind of vibe and imagery going
around and it
it almost feels right to me because it's
like superman kind of comes out of that
era
and then seeing truth justice the
american way and like that
aesthetic you know i thought was a
really cool choice for this movie so
but speaking of what you're talking
about like that old school american way
like i think that's why some
i think that's why this was getting a
very divisive crowd you know amongst
critics and audiences because
we're so used to superman being that
like charming
really light-hearted type of uh hero you
know they
that's why superman and batman have
always sort of been that perfect balance
yeah but now with this new take on
superman
i think people are just having a
difficult time accepting it like yo this
is
extremely different than what we've ever
seen before
of superman like it's exceptionally dark
it's
it's way way more serious than we've
ever seen it like the tone throughout
is very serious yeah you would expect
that from like a batman film
yeah but not from a superman film and i
think if you're willing to readjust you
would totally see the art that they're
going for
it's like they said let's forget
everything we know about superman let's
just take some facts
we'll you know give a modern day
interpretation of it and yeah i thought
they totally executed it perfectly it is
it is very much a film of
of our time of this point in time
reason to see number two cavill
now speaking of fresh take of superman
this is he's probably
one of the bigger reasons this is a
fresh take on superman some people are
saying like he loses the charm and i'm i
didn't think so i thought
for a dark serious character he still
had a level of charm
there to you know to back it up and you
can still see like no it's still
superman just a much more darker version
yeah he's awesome at it you can see you
can you can feel the struggle and
there's something
i like watching him because you can
always tell there's something going on
underneath the surface yeah he doesn't
talk a lot but i mean
you know you get the struggle between i
am not
of this world where do i belong and also
that sort of i'm a kid from kansas you
know like
yeah kind of like that wanderer lost boy
observing kind of
alien from another planet you know like
yeah it makes sense for him to be this
sort of quiet
you know like a lot of the choices that
they made with how they're going to
portray
superman specifically when i was
watching i was going how could i
thought of this before yeah because this
makes more sense
in a real world for a kid to be this way
yeah
like it's more of the outsider more like
the james dean kind of guy
yeah rebel without a cape
i did notice his chest hair was popping
out through his uh
his superman's outfit
i noticed that because i figured you
would notice that
and i think this superman 2 is a lot
more identifiable than
any superman we've got him before
everyone's felt like they don't belong
before and i thought that was a cool
thing to play with
he is a little more accessible to people
and he is a little more conflicted that
way
as a personal opinion i think a lot of
us well i think all of us have a certain
sense of loneliness
and you know to tap into that with clark
kent is
very interesting and there's this great
talk in uh kill bill volume 2
about how superman's uh secret identity
is really clark kent
and the real identity of superman is
superman
you know it's cow and in this movie you
really do get that sense like you're
watching
cal l for this movie you're not
necessarily watching clark kent
being this guy you're watching cal he's
not jumping into phone booths and stuff
like that
and then just take it around i do always
wonder how he fits that cape inside of
his like closed
roll though he just never takes that
sport coat off
but yeah it is more of a kalel movie
than it is a card kent movie they call
him cal more than they call him
yeah his name is cal basically yeah
reason is scene number three
fresh take on lois lane amy adams man
amy adams she's beautiful yeah i like
watching her at first i was a little
confused
she was showing up at the ship and
everything i'm like is she gonna find
out who this guy is
and i i thought that was smart actually
eventually like
you know everyone knows how it always
goes with superman and lois lane there's
the clark kent lois
story and then she falls in love with
superman but she doesn't know he's
really clerking yeah but yeah i know
with this movie to see lois lane know
who superman is up front
you know and like actually investigate
it and figure out that that made so much
sense i i said earlier like how come we
never thought lois lane was capable of
this before
well yeah she's not just a damsel in
distress in this movie like she's
actually you know
she's gutsy she's a reporter you know
she's she's used to
you know weaseling her way into
situations to get the the scoops and the
heart hitting
yeah evidence i mean i thought there was
a little bit of an underdevelopment with
the character like just
a slight underdevelopment like i don't
feel like we out of all the characters i
feel like she was the one we got to know
the least out of the iconic characters
of the superman movies that we really
know
even so like they set her up at least
well enough to explore her for a sequel
yeah and explore the relationship
between her and uh
l even more and that's what's cool it's
like you're seeing lois lane falling in
love with cal
yeah not clark kent or superman like
you're falling in love with cal
like she knows who this guy is and she's
falling in love with that guy
i also enjoy as an extension of that the
way that coda becomes
the surprise is when he shows up as
clark not
clark as superman although i thought
there was some lack of romance going on
i i thought that her and uh cavill
played off each other very well too yeah
they have a good relationship and they
have a good interaction and then
they gave her a bit more of a
substantial you know
role you can see the the intrigue
between the two of them
like it makes sense that way i just like
how it was in another ignorant
dan's little distress story like yeah to
call someone a great [ __ ] reporter
and then to not be able to see like
clark can't work on the
daily planet it's superman it would be
like the stupidest reporter ever reason
to see number four
action and effects wow
what a movie with action and effects
even in the first 10 minutes that's what
i thought was cool in the first 10
minutes they made jarrell
a badass like he was kicking ass and
everything is like this
this is a scientist who has the all the
knowledge in the of krypton
and now he's kicking ass at the same
time
and it makes sense he's not arnold but
he can't take care of himself yeah he's
like shooting up guys taking on zod and
stuff
first ten minutes sets up essentially
what the tone
and style will be pretty much for most
of the movie
and then at one point it becomes like 45
minutes
of it's not like one long action scene
like a transformers movie but it's
it's kind of like non-stop action yeah
there does become a lot of action when
when zod and his people finally full out
invade it's all good it's all well
executed and the effects are great
for me a little bit it became just like
there's so much action and so kinetic
that it was a little much for me and
that's not to say the story goes away at
all but
but you know there was it does go from
being like lots and lots of story to
like whoa
really big action yeah and it kind of
feels like it's of a
slightly different movie i mean i
personally didn't feel that way like i
i mean there was a moment where i was
like this there's a little too much
action right now yeah
but it was like i remember having that
thought like one time for
most of it it's still like you're not
zoning out through it like it's still
badass yeah it's incredible action
sequences that
is just at warp speed yes
that level of intensity with the action
makes sense of where the story is
currently going at that moment and it's
not gratuitous that way
like it makes sense you know the scenes
were just beautiful like i love that
action scene in the small town
where uh he's taking on the two people
from the from zod's team
yes this is how superman would have a
fist fight it was so unique and
and the effects made it look very
believable i never got pulled out going
like those are effects like it was
always cool i found myself going
dang it oh
[ __ ] what that fight with zod and
uh superman at the end talk about
giving the audience what they probably
want well and that that
that fight specifically is is a bit it's
like it's
different because it's it's more
intimate so in a weird way when it's
just them two showing down i thought
that fight was was incredible
it's in a lot of ways what you know the
matrix revolutions they had
neo and smith go at it at a city and a
lot of people didn't like that for the
fight and this one though i it's like no
you hear superman and zog going at it
and
they do it in the way like yes that is
how an imagination should go oh yeah
it's perfect well let's [ __ ] it up
metropolis and turn it into the city of
ruins
and also with the effects i gotta say i
i dug their tech
like all their weird uh sort of
kryptonian
oh yeah technology and stuff like the
faces appearing to talk to you yeah like
the the
it's all very it's not just holograms
it's yeah it's elegant
it's elemental yeah it's like it's
actual tangible like shifting i don't
know it was cool that way it was
yeah they created a great world oh and
the way he flies and stuff that was
so [ __ ] cool like it's always like
wow
wow yeah they really like sonic boom you
know yeah
they really played with like sound
barriers and stuff like that the things
that happen when stuff flies fast yeah i
know this isn't a category but the sound
effects are really cool too
sound effects are so ticking they're
taken for granted it sound man
and the sound and this is really cool
too well they say like punches and stuff
and really
you you feel the hits yeah they say like
the best effects are the stuff you don't
realize are there
and i feel like sound gets that but like
to the worst degree because you don't
realize they're there and then you don't
realize and then you just take them for
granted
yeah exactly but yeah definitely i mean
the sound design and everything is great
yeah from from visual to special to
sound like all the effects are great
reason to see number five michael
shannon
general zod general zod from the uh i
will
fight i will find him he says it like
nine times and then he finally shut it
funny just because it was like he says
it he says it again you're like is this
an alternate take
is he going to say it more times and
then he finally does saying you're like
there it is
he said it no he's shannon is shannon is
always good like everyone knows that
about yeah even if you haven't seen a
lot of michael shannon performances
i'm sure you heard this guy it never
does a bad show yeah you didn't
you don't need to have seen any of his
movies to know that michael shannon is a
crazy awesome actor
exactly you know he's i don't think he's
like one of the best villains of all
time you've seen in a superhero movie
but for what they
they provide you know he's for the most
part he's a fully developed villain
you you get him because of you know like
how on krypton they say that all the
babies are genetically made and you know
they're all like have a purpose before
they're
you know brought into life and so it
makes sense for zod to be
this guy yeah and shannon portrays him
perfectly he gives it he doesn't play
him like i'm an evil guy
no and there's a human you know that's
what is so great is that every
every scene he was in i could totally
tell that this guy
believes in what he's doing he believes
that what he's doing is right because
that's what he's supposed to do
yeah and that's the biggest strength to
his performance is you can
you can just tell that he believes it so
hard yeah because there's a lot of it
has to do with like he's just not some
evil guy
with like a power trip like a mustang he
really thinks like no i'm doing this
because i love krypton
yeah i'm doing this because yeah he
thinks he's doing it for the better good
you know but it's it's a debate with
this guy you know he he goes
toe-to-toe with debates with the ghosts
of jarrell yeah you know like
this dude seriously has like messed up
philosophies going on
and he's trying to execute them at the
same time he's a soldier
you know he's a he's like a warlord in a
way well yeah
but that's that's what informs his mind
you know it's like that's
if he was indeed like like an engineer
you know being it's like that's what
drives and that's what informs his
very existence and that's why that
speech he gives to henry cavill towards
the end
is that moment he just crushed that
because it was like
you know i have no more people yeah i
don't have no purpose
in a weird way i like sort of felt that
for yeah i was like this guy's whole
world is gone
like yeah he has not like the whole
reason he doesn't exist for a purpose
anymore because his purpose is moot and
like
that's i i thought that was great you
know and he's a great antagonist for
superman like perfect first villain for
this movie
because i thought there was just the
right amount of emphasis on him usually
in these movies when it comes to
you know a reboot of an origin tale they
don't give a lot of emphasis on the
villain or they give too much emphasis
on the villain this one i thought they
gave just the right amount he fits into
this ensemble in the world perfectly
and as playing an antagonist to superman
perfect
i want to say equal but there was just
enough more of
zod to be like yes he is a good threat
to
uh to cal he has all the knowledge of
krypton he has the experience of being
like a murderer and then when he comes
to earth he's
developing the powers that kal-el has
when he comes to earth and it was cool
how cause i remember in the in superman
part two
the one that took place after the donner
one he was he was just
readjusting to everything really well
sometimes
he's like i gotta handle this [ __ ] but
in this one it was cool to see him
explore that and
it made sense too when he got a hold of
it when he was like i wasn't trained to
master my senses i was
programmed to master my senses that's
why i'm able to keep up with you man
you know don't try to defeat me because
i will [ __ ] you up well
and i think that zod is a great choice
as a villain generally because it's like
it all ties back into the core of the
movie because it's like krypton has been
destroyed
yeah that's the whole reason clark is on
earth you know that
they're both sort of orphaned from this
planet in a way
yeah and it's two sides of a coin so i
think that's a really cool way to bring
this new
story in because it's all it all hits
home that way
you got clark who's this guy who's lost
and comes from another planet and
doesn't really know a lot about his
history and stuff like that and he's
he's in a search for that and then you
got
zod the one person alive who is
like him you know and this is
technically
like the one sort of family member you
know in a way that he's got left but but
who's heartbroken because they lost
so they both come from a similar origin
you know like
that it was cool to see them go toe to
toe i like how they have the genetically
engineered like
children on krypton they always say the
last son of krypton the last and the
krypton
but if zod was a national born baby he
wouldn't be the last on the krypton
anymore
so they still they still keep it as he
is the last son of krypton superman
i think it's easy to take his
performance for granted in this movie
just because because he's michael janet
michael shannon knows how to portray a
guy
well and work well with other cast
members he doesn't chew up the screen
yeah exactly you know he's he's not like
this big outlandish performance
superman i will defeat you i will
find you i you will do this for me
huntsman yeah but just because michael
shannon
embodies it and does it subtly in a way
people might not notice like no this guy
does a great [ __ ] job in the movie
plus he rocks a crazy goatee
reason to see number six directing and
cinematography
i feel like zack snyder was really
influenced by like chris nolan's
directing
and jj abrams directing i'm just happy
there's a zack snyder movie out where
we're not gonna have to endure endless
uh slow-mo jokes oh yeah cuz there's no
slow motion
so he must have been listening to
somebody it is a totally different
uh style than i've ever seen this guy do
before like it was handheld for most of
it
yeah a handheld a superman movie sounds
weird but
it actually worked for this specific
take it it brought that sense of realism
and
darkness behind it yeah and snyder's
choice on it was cool i like his choices
to have like the
uh the camera zoom in on like the crash
zooms
on like a lot of the cg effects and
stuff to add that sense of realism
something i think
he saw from dj yeah you know it was it
was a great take and i loved the tone
that he established too like it was
because you when you're doing a lot of
like cutting back team past and present
and other characters
it's hard to find that tone where yes
it'll all make sense but he found the
perfect tone for this film well
and and he intercut it seemed like he
knew he had a good sense of when to go
from present to flashbacks
when to go back and explain things about
clark's about you know superman
it's zack snyder the movie looks great
and i like the juxtaposition
you have between the sort of grungier
grittier present day cinematography
yeah yeah and then the really rich
vibrant you know flashback
cinematography
just honestly like this whole movie
looked awesome there was such a
grittiness behind
every single shot you know like he has
an incredible cinematographer working on
this phone
because every shot looked cool and it it
it looked real that's what i liked it
felt
real and and it felt alive everything
about it felt so cool
but i felt like snyder and with david
goyer as the writer too i i sort of feel
like they had
a uh a feeling that look most of our
audience already knows superman yeah
so let's not treat them like hey we're
re we're gonna at like in the moment
where he becomes superman i was like oh
okay i guess he's superman now yeah it
was a little bit like
we got here a little fast but sure well
because it wasn't like
and this is when he puts the suit on
yeah that's right i mean
this is when this happened like that's
what i mean they treat them like yo
look we know you guys have seen the
superman tail a billion times already
so a lot of the stuff that we have to
give you we're gonna give it to you
but we're not going to put all our
emphasis on that you know we're going to
put our emphasis on things you guys
haven't explored before haven't seen yet
so i think that's where some of the
disappointments coming in on where
people are expecting an a to b to c
origin story because we see so many
origin comic book movies now
yeah that i think that's what people are
wanting but in this one it's it's kind
of got a little bit of a batman begins
feel with
coming back being past and present it's
got a lot of it's it's actually a
perfect companion piece of batman begins
in my opinion they don't treat their
audience like they're idiots in this
film so i i think some people
wanted to see see the same [ __ ] movie
again but yeah no like snyder and nolan
working together i thought it was a
perfect one-two combo well yeah and i've
always said this with zack snyder it's
say what you will about him if you give
him good material i think he can make a
good movie and i think that that is
proven again here it's like
left to his own devices maybe not so
much i know a lot of people don't like
sucker punch
but this movie you know he's got a
script from some people who have proven
their worth
yeah and then you bring in his instincts
visually and and and for you know pacing
and stuff like that
and i gotta say this is the best story i
think he's pulled off he
usually is more of the visual kind of
guy but in in this particular movie it's
it seemed more about the story than the
visual feast
which i thought that's what i was
concerned about i thought it was going
to be just another visual feast
no it compliments it it complements well
it's great to look at but it's not like
ah look at that shot and that frame
it complements well it's not distracting
in that way you notice it but not in a
way where it's like check out how cool
our angles are
because it's not like they they made
this visual feast subtle and then they
amplified the story like no they
amplified the story but they also gave
us
one hell of a visual experience at the
same time so to get
both in the same film was awesome but
what i will say though about the
skyrocketing action is that
we have i think as a superman fans we've
been waiting for a movie that can pull
that off that's true yeah no and
and that's why i'm i'm a bit mixed on
i'm not saying like oh it's bad
reason to see number seven the score
beautiful music when i was leaving the
theater i just couldn't get it out of my
my head it's the perfect han zimmer man
what a
composer yeah this dude knows how to do
it
right every [ __ ] time yeah man i like
han zimmer's work and i think it
complements this movie well
it's not a batman clone which is nice
yeah yeah
um it's got that superman tone in the in
the music definitely yeah it's
definitely a different tone and
different feel and it gives
you know compliments the movie again it
gives it you know
an oomph without being distracting yeah
it's got it's got that sense of uh
heroism in it but it also matches the
film because this isn't like a heroic
movie i think yeah not in that way
nothing like the haha
yeah like shooting we're gonna be like
at the end like superman yeah yeah
yeah but the music still it still fits
the whole
all the music fits the the world
perfectly even even zod's kind of like
super evil kind of music is is pretty
neat too yeah yeah i like it all a lot
you know like this guy knows how to make
theme songs for characters i remember he
he has the bane song his joker song and
you know he
now he has you know general sods and
superman so this
this dude is just he's a you should do
every comic book
reason to see number eight joerl
they made him way more badass than we've
ever seen jorelle before the only time
i've seen jarel this cool
was in the superman adventures from the
90s like they made him really cool
in the cartoon and i was so glad they
made him a badass in this one too kyle's
coming from
you know dna from a real
genius slash badass only makes sense
for cal-el to sort of evolve into that
as well
yeah you know and so they show like yo
and it's in his dna he's
he's gonna be something [ __ ] amazing
despite wherever this guy is
yeah before it was just like hey if
kryptonians go to earth that's where
they become cool yeah
no it's like no there's some kryptonians
who are cool and jarrell's a big part of
why yeah i mean their their playing
field is different but i mean
jorel as we come to know him at least
through this particular movie it's like
you know he's
he's a strong honorable smart you know
guy
you know you do get to see him kick a
couple asses but he's also you know you
can feel the gravity of what's going on
in his world and i think russell crowe
you know brought something good to that
character so oh russell crowe does a
cool job perfectly cast i thought
to have him uh sort of be like an aide
to lois lane and to
kal-el uh during a lot of those intense
sequences
that was pretty neat i i like how it was
more than just a hologram of his face
like what they did with marlon brando
yeah it was
it was actually like a human walking
around and stuff jarrell was he was a
cool character way more fleshed out than
i thought even the marlon brando
character
sorry i know it's gonna piss off some of
you but i thought that he was
more intriguing to watch than marlon
brano's interpretation he's another
great actor in this movie who's not
trying to outshine anyone here you know
like
he he does another subtle job and he's
another he's another performance in it
that's like hey if you pay attention
you'll see he's doing a great job as
well reasons not to see
lack of romance there's just one reason
i mean you know everyone is probably
expecting uh like
a big romantic element in this because
that's what we expect from lois lane and
clark kent
but it's not really felt in this movie
which i could see being a bummer
but for what they gave in this film i
wasn't too distracted by it but there
are people who are complaining about
how there is a lack of romance and i i
want it on the list because i
agree that yes there is a lack of
romance but
there's still like a billion other
things that are [ __ ] awesome in this
film
well yeah and their relationship still
makes sense though that's the thing is
it's it's not a particularly romantic
movie it's not like lois and clark are
going to go on a date
you know but yeah but um you believe
this sort of magnetism and the
attraction the intrigue between them
yeah you believe the relationship that
the movie gives you it's just not
that same you know oh you know like roma
textbook romantic thing ryan's consensus
man of steel is the reason movies are
made man of steel is the reason movies
are made
yes i think there's some flaws with it
like even in the first
hour or so i thought it was there's some
uneven pacing and some rushing
but anyway i love like 98
of this movie so yeah i definitely think
it's one of the best movies of the year
jerry's consensus i think there are
definitely a lot of reasons to see man
of steel
there are definitely a lot of reasons to
see man of steel
you know i i enjoyed this movie quite a
bit i'm not in love with it just because
you know
some of the action was a bit much for me
but i thought throughout there's lots of
great stuff i really like the cast and i
like the take on the story
some of those flashbacks had me a little
misty-eyed so uh
so it's good stuff definitely check it
out all right guys thanks for checking
out our review from nanosteel
why don't you go ahead scroll that
comment box below and tell us
if you saw man of steel what did you
think of the movie did you love it did
you hate it
no matter what the opinion is we just
want to know and once you're done with
that if you want to check out more
episodes of reasons to see go ahead and
click the link right here
and if you want to go ahead and follow
us on facebook you can click the link
right here
or if you want to follow me ryan wright
on twitter click the link
right here and last but not least if you
want to get updated every time a new
review
or a video is out subscribe
click this button to subscribe superman
fans
you know what's cool about the the mixed
reactions on this movie is everyone's
lightening up towards superman returns
which i thought was all right
i thought that movie was all right and
when when it came out it was like this
is okay
and then a year later was like [ __ ] that
movie yeah and so now everyone's going
you know what bryan singer's movie
wasn't half bad
so i'm happy to see that happen it's one
of those movies that strange superman
returns because it has like a
75 on rotten tomatoes yet everyone i
encounter is like
i hated that movie indiana jones four
syndrome yeah right
he's like the movie the good reviews but
no one [ __ ] lies
if indie five comes out everyone's gonna
be like i hate
crystal skull wasn't that bad this sucks
you know it's like it's the same thing
that keeps happening
but i actually kind of like superman
returns it's a love letter man
i like superman returns too actually you
know and i don't like it more than man
of steel
but i did like superman returning i
enjoyed it quite a bit
bran ralph man yeah tom cruise looking
like
he sounds like tom tom it doesn't look
like tomorrow it sounds like tom
cruising it looks like christopher reeve
yeah yeah there you go that's that's the
way to do it it's a weird what if
combination i like henry cavill's
american accent in this movie
i do too people were freaking out about
that but you know i was like
carl is from a different planet his dad
sounds
british so for him to be played by a
british actor he's not american anyway
like he grows up in america it actually
seems
more fitting to have a foreign actor
play superman yeah than an american
actor but it's
yeah actually it's more identifiable
especially when it's taking place in
america
exactly that's a good point i never
thought about that actually yeah that's
a great point thank you
it makes sense for all of them like
spider like uh andrew garfield the
spider-man
and uh what you may call it and and bale
as batman
they're all characters who are sort of
like lonely people who feel
misunderstood and outsiders and stuff
that's true and so to
have them played by british people get
one in america it's easier to get that
feeling
but i think i think henry cavill has the
greatest excuse because it's like you
know
already from a different planet and
jarrell is already australian yeah
this guy is you know from across the
country across the world you know it's
like it makes sense
uh so reasons to cast henry cavill
and subscribe
you